[Music]
[Applause]
Bob Sturm is a co-host of the hard line
it's an afternoon Drive show on the
ticket in Dallas and Bob kind enough to
join us Bob um you got five assistant
coaches who were fired
uh or they were let go or not brought
back whatever the semantics are with
this so what is the message that's being
sent here by Jerry Jones
well you know that's that's always the
million dollar question Dan and I think
to a certain extent it starts with you
know who's coming back from the
coordinator position uh but you know in
general the idea that you're losing Dan
Quinn feels relatively assured Kellen
Moore feels like a coin flip and and I I
suppose uh the the opportunity if you
will or at least the obligation to to
kind of reimagine your coaching staff
and maybe even your offensive scheme
which I would be all for uh is is clear
and present and they're I guess they're
getting out ahead of that with guys with
expiring deals maybe allowing them to go
pursue other possibilities that's fine
uh I expect we're not just talking about
tier three assistant coaches being
allowed to expire I I assume there's
there's more sweeping changes a foot but
uh but again with Jerry uh he's he's
pretty good about protecting this card
until he has to tell the world but you
were talking about offensive philosophy
maybe changing that offensive philosophy
go into detail about that well in
general and this is a sweeping
generalization but allow me that in the
sense that Jason Garrett and Scott
Linehan installed an offense that was
either for Tony Romo or for very very
young Dak Prescott and very very young
Dak Prescott wasn't making a lot of
money but he was also definitely driving
the bus and as this thing has evolved
and as Mike McCarthy has taken over I
was under the impression that McCarthy
was going to bring in a lot of the stuff
that he likes to do and do a lot less of
what Jason Garrett likes to do but when
you look at some key plays
and they're running curls across the
board again just like they were with
Jason Garrett where you're where you
pause it two seconds into the play Dan
and you say okay if you're quarterback
where are you going with the ball right
here and there's no sort of rub routes
or or horizontal attacks Crossings you
know things that modern NFL does without
any any sort of uh uh hesitation the
Cowboys really don't do enough of that
so I I think Kellen Moore can design
great plays I don't know that he can
design a great offense and those are two
very different things and I would like
to see you know the Cowboys do way more
of what Dak does well and weigh less of
what they want him to do which I guess
is kind of Tony Romo's stuff back there
in the pocket I I think Prescott can be
fine I do think their offense doesn't
necessarily suit them especially if
you're not going to give them enough
Playmakers uh be on cd-lam it's pretty
it's pretty bare but if they evaluated
Dak accurately I mean there's a reason
why he went where he went in the draft
here yeah and what they're asking him to
do he's not Tony Romo but but are they
asking him to be Tony Romo I think too
often they are and I think this whole
league is filled with teams that get to
contract time with a guy and they say
okay on his best day can he be at the
very back of the top ten yes on his
worst day is he still an average NFL
starter yes okay so are you willing to
give him the going rate for a
quarterback and most of these teams say
yes they panic because they realize the
alternative is nothing and so uh the
Giants are about to do this uh no
disrespect to Jalen hurts but they're
about to get him 45 a year and and and
and are we sure Jalen hurts is a top
five guy in this league well this year
he was great but he's also on a loaded
roster so all around the league teams
are making these decisions we don't have
Mahomes we don't have uh uh you know
Josh Allen or Joe burrow so what are we
going to do and just about all of them
say all right extend him at the going
rate well the going rate now Dan is five
for 200 and that's a lot of money if a
guy isn't the savior yeah I've just
wondered that it always felt like when
they run it sets up the play action I
feel more confident with Jack with that
kind of game plan and I love Pollard I I
didn't want to keep Zeke I didn't want
to extend him I think he's washed but
you know have him do things where
it's you know second and and four and
instead of he's got to create he's not
one of those guys that I want passing
the ball 35 40 times a game
right and and look there's there's guys
like that in this league and that's fine
you know uh I don't think anyone wants
Lamar Jackson throwing it 40 times a
game there's there's guys in this league
who are really effective but you've got
to get the mix right and part of that is
the Run pass option the ability you
don't you're not even calling a run per
se you are making the defense decide uh
they're picking their poison and so yeah
I think I think the Cowboys need to lean
into more of that and frankly a guy like
Greg Roman being available actually does
uh at least at least piqued my interest
now the Cowboys are are such an outlier
Dan in the sense that as you just
mentioned everybody kind of knows that
Zeke is not your best running back
option and in fact the question is now
is he employable in the National
Football League and yet the Cowboys
started him nearly every game this year
and and you know they gave him the
Lion's Share over Tony Pollard and it's
just it it all goes back to is the head
coach in Dallas allowed to be a head
coach because as far back as I can
remember a head coach can decide who
starts a running back but in Dallas it
feels like it's bigger than that it
feels like it's a Jones family decision
and it's a Well we love him he's part of
the family and you know and they they
they almost make loyalty A Fault in the
National Football League because they're
so darn loyal and if you go back a dozen
or 13 years you could say two coaches
and two quarterbacks meanwhile the 49ers
have gone to how many championship games
over the last Dozen Years with like four
or five different quarterbacks and
you're just four or five different
coaches and and sometimes change can be
too much but but I swear the Cowboys are
loyal to a fault and and it doesn't
serve them at all well also ego Jerry
wants to show that he's right with Zeke
Elliott and I'm sure there are a lot of
people said no you got everything you
could get at or with Jack you know I'm
going to show you Jason Garrett yes
exactly so loyal to a fault but then you
go back to Jimmy Johnson where he wasn't
loyal to Jimmy Johnson and ended up
costing but you know this goes back to
Mike McCarthy uh are we expecting more
are we expecting too much out of Mike
McCarthy given the constraints that he
has behind the scenes
wow I mean that's uh that's sort of the
the uh the riddle here in some respects
because I expect a lot out of Mike
McCarthy uh as as somebody who followed
him very closely in Green Bay uh I
thought this was a massive upgrade from
Jason Garrett uh I I really thought that
uh he is probably one of those guys that
Jerry would trust enough to empower him
and to allow him to sort of name his
staff and then the first day on the job
he's like you know what nothing about
this offense is going to change uh
Kellen Moore will still be coordinated
and uh you know we we love where they
are and developing Dak and I'm like Mike
you're an offensive guy since like 1993
with Joe Montana in Kansas City and
everything and you're saying you don't
want to change anything that just got
Jason Garrett fired uh I I want Mike to
grab the wheel and to basically say I
need it this way now because it's his
reputation on the line but at at almost
60 years old I get the impression Mike
is is totally fine with sharing the load
sharing the responsibility and sharing
the decision making which I'm not
positive this franchise needs but or the
wants but I do know that's what they
need they need somebody to to have a
fresh set of eyes on this thing not to
confirm what they've been doing for the
last decade which as you pointed out is
kind of the type of person the Jones
family would like to hire is somebody
who just tells them how right they are
all the time how are the fans
when you guys take calls on your show
uh discussed it I mean the the fans the
fans do not enjoy Cowboy football
anymore uh the ones that I hear from the
ones that I hear from Dan this team
could start 14-0 next year and they
would still be upset that this team is
going to do something dumb in the
playoffs and they're going to continue
this three-decade run in the desert and
uh the fact the fact that you haven't
won a Super Bowl in three decades or 27
years is not that original I mean the
49ers have actually been a year longer
it's the fact you haven't been to an NFC
Championship game in 27 years that's
almost impossible to do especially with
the resources of the Cowboys and
definitely with the prime time TV
positioning of the Cowboys and all the
chatter and the ratings they generate
but they have avoided the NFC title game
they have avoided a single win in the
divisional round for 27 years and just
think about what that says but if I said
to the Dallas fan base you could have a
new coach or a new quarterback
wow
boy that might be a tie
um they're they've talked themselves
into the fact that Sean Payton is
smarter than Mike McCarthy even though I
kind of think they're the same guy with
a different marketing department because
I can't throw the owner in that question
yeah oh now now we're talking but uh
okay owner coach quarterback owner 100
you know partly because the owner has
insisted on being the general manager
even though let's be honest you and I
both know he looks at as much tape as uh
as my wife does
it's not a lot but uh but but yes there
is a feeling and and I don't want to be
disrespectful here but there is a
feeling that as long as Jerry walks the
Earth nothing is truly going to change
about Cowboy football
there's your pull quote right there from
uh this in interview uh Bob thanks for
joining us we appreciate it and uh good
luck thank you buddy it's an honor thank
you Bob Sturm he is uh co-host of the
hard line the afternoon Drive show on
1310 The Ticket in Dallas